in domestic news there was big news from
American history this week specifically
about Warren G Hardy
America's 29th president whose greatest
achievement was dying two years into his
first term let's be honest no one knows
much about warren g harding but this
week that may have permanently changed
we're getting a first look at some of
the love letters that president warren g
harding wrote to his mistress a century
ago page after page of Harding's
handwriting described in detail what he
described as his eager passion wild
jealous reverent wistful love for his
neighbor's wife okay okay that's
actually a little misleading because
believe me these are not eager jealous
and wistful love letters
these are smutty frogs someone see a 40
year old mother of two should be reading
them on her Kindle because this is this
is an actual passage from his actual
letters I feel that there will never be
any relief until I take a long deep wild
draft on your lips and then bury my face
on your pillow in breasts wouldn't you
like to get sopping wet out on superior
not the lake for the joy of fevered
fondling and melting kisses I've got to
say damn Warren you nasty
no one no one is going to be able to
look at you in the same way Harding
before all I could see when I looked at
you with your eyebrows like mozzarella
sticks covered in pubic hair and gels
like sour cream funneled into a condom
but now history will only remember you
and your lake based erotic poetry
actually they will remember one more
thing Barroso told that just as Anthony
Weiner goes by Carlos danger Warren
Harding had a nickname for a certain
part of his Anatomy
he called it Jerry yes warren g harding
America's 29 president called his Jerry
which is which is actually funny cos
Gerald Ford called his warren g harding
i actually actually believe we have an
artist rendering of jerry that's what he
looked like back then it was a different
time um Harding actually writes about
Jerry in his letters saying and again I
quote you recall Jerry he told me to say
that you are the best and darlingest in
the world and if he could have but one
wish it would be to be held in your
darling embrace and be thrilled by your
pink lips
I will say this I will say this for
Warren Harding as a president he was
terrible but as an R&B lyricist he was
way ahead of his time he really puts the
Warren G into warren g harding